what you're looking at is a simplified
credit card thing now I the question was
posed why get a credit card if it's no
good
for actual credit well you only took
like that this number is a very very
important 55
does anyone know why this number is
important it's somewhat arbitrary 55 55
is this industry standard number of days
from when you get learned the amount on
your credit card 55 days elapse and then
you've got to pay then they're gonna
start charging you interest if you pay
off what you know you have gone to the
shops like 30 times in that month right
and you've racked up you know a few
thousand dollars of debt that you now
okay if you pay that off within the 55
days they don't charge you any interest
they just charge you
well whatever you've actually pictures
okay you wait after this then they give
a snapshot okay 55 so here's the way my
credit card works think about this I'm
not easier to actually borrow money I'm
not using it to actually borrow money so
there I'm not actually paying any
interest okay but over the course of a
month I might spend say $3,000 on
groceries on petrol on resources on all
these kinds of things
now that $3,000 remember when I tapped
when I tap who paid for that was it me
the bank paid right
so my bank account is completely
untouched right so the money that I've
earned
stays in my bank account what's my money
doing while it's still in my bank
account it's Ernie interests right now
eventually I'm gonna have to pay that
$3,000 back eventually but if I can if I
can hold it off right if I can hold on
to that amount of money for an extra 55
days and if I can do that constantly
then I'm going to make interest back on
that and it really makes a difference it
adds up so have a look at this with
together this is the March thing okay so
at the beginning of the month there 55
days it starts ticking as soon as the
monthly views and you will have what's
called a credit limit right generally I
think if you get a credit card if you've
got a credit history etc it starts at
like four thousand dollars or something
like that and they'll want to increase
it I'll let you have a think about why
banks is circu you increasing your
creditors now the 55 days been used and
then we start to use your credit cards
you make transactions now this fifty
five days it starts from the first day
of the month okay so when you buy this
furniture a week later think about this
how many days do you have left to pay
off visitin it's going to be fifty five
take away whatever number of days
already plus which is seven days so I
guess you've got 48 days to pay off this
thing right what about the hot way even
that's right sixteen days have passed so
I guess you've got 39 days to pay that
off and if I've got things that are
closer to the end of the month then I
have progressively less time to pay them
because they're all counting 55 from the
closi balance right that's how much I
owe them that's how much I owe the
credit card but they're going to ask me
to pay now here's why right if you I
asked you to have that bear with you
very frequently a card will have a
minimum payment that they're requiring
you to me okay
so there's a they're going to not charge
you interest but they're still going to
say look low rate low fee they're gonna
charge you something okay so therefore
in this particular on this plan the
minimum payment is ten dollars or three
percent of the closed accounts okay it's
just kind of represents your credit card
monthly fee it's not paying off your
debt it's just the fee that you have to
pay just for the right of using the
credit card
so 3% of this amount a 3% of this amount
is $52 41 cents so that's more than $10
so they're gonna charge you that amount
due date 24th of April what is that it
is 55 days after March the 1st now have
a look at the next month with me this is
the next month what's happened
reowww evening what's happened there
there bought some more stuff then they
said oh I better pay up now why is this
about what it is yeah that's right that
was that's what we're still only and
that's what you should do each lunch
when you get a credit card
so let that debt sit there because as
soon as you pass this they're gonna
charge you exorbitant interest rate
amounts right so pays it off and then
there's more transactions by the way
waited until the very last moment
what maximum features because I want to
maximize the number of days when my
money is still why money and is earning
the interest